مشاهدينا في الاستوديو الفنان عبد الرحمن
العزاوي اهلا وسهلا فيك عبد الرحمن صباح
الخير صباح الورد يا عبد الرحمن شلونك
والله تمام حياه سعيده جدا ومبتسمه
رومانسيه
طيب عبد الرحمن يعني اغنيه او اغنيتين على
الاقل حققوا هذا النجاح الهائل وعدد
مشاهدات مهول على اليوتيوب خلينا نبدا
باغنيه تاخذ العقل
ليش باللهجه السعوديه او لهجه خليجيه مش
بلهجتك المحليه اللهجه العراقيه اول شيء
نصبح عليكم وعلى الساده المشاهدين
اختياري اللهجه الخليجيه كان عندي اعمالنا
عراقيه سابقا تكون عراقي يعني فحبيت اني
اغير وادخل مجال اخر يعني فكان في اتفاق
مع الشعر ليبدا بالاغتين هما وباقي الامر
ايضا وكان معاي الموزم الاماراتي محمد
الجسمي فصارت خلطه سعوديه اماراتيه عراقيه
فطلعت بهذا الموسيقى الهويه لها يمكن
دائما هذه اختلاف الاذواق واختلاف المشارب
تعطيك شيء جديد انعكس هذا الشيء على
اغانيك عبد الرحمن طبعا اليوم السنجل تغني
عن البوم طبعا
مرات البوم يعني يتكون من عشرات الاغاني
العشرين اغنيه مثلا اغنيه وعشر اغاني ما
تنجح منها فقط اغنيه وحده يغنيك عن البوم
كامل
ليش النجاح للاغنيه الواحده انت تحتاج
اصلا انه لانك تحتاج اغنيه واحده فقط هي
تنجح فتكون كفيله انه هي توصل للناس وتجدد
وجودك مع الجمهور احنا حابين نسمع منك شيء
بس قبل هيك كنت حابه بس اسالك طيب ايش
معنى ليش برايك اغنيه تاخذ العقل قدرت
انها تحقق 52 مليون مشاهده هذا رقم مهول
على اليوتيوب ايش معنى مع انها برضه يعني
اغنيه مش بطيئه وايضا ليست سريعه يعني
ايقاعها مش ايقاع رقص هذول الاغاني اللي
دائما بيحضروا بكثير متابعات والله شوفي
اول شيء اول شيء توفيق من رب العالمين هذه
اول نقطه ثانيا جهود الكادر العمل يعني
شاعر والموزع وايضا كانوا لهم سبب في
النجاح ثالثا الغناء كان باحساس عالي
كان بحب العمل كان بحب وصل للناس بحب وحبه
يعني
سمعكم الاغنيه يلا
عن عيون الناس ودي امنعك حتى صوتك بس انا
اللي اسمعك تاخذ العقل بجمالك تاخذ غيري
لو شافك يا خوفي يتبعك لك شعوري قبل عيني
ابتسم ينهزم حزني قربك ينهزم انت ما خليت
فرصه للعتب تدري لينا الحين احس اني بحلم
حبيبي
[موسيقى]
حبيبي حبيبي
انت حبيبي
الله الله
أربع دقائق اوكي طيب اليوم في خلطات
الشباب مختلفين في اغاني السبعينات
والثمانينات والتسعينات وحتى الالفينات
اليوم في روح جديده شنو هذه الروح لمن
تتوجهون بالبدايه شوف كل جيل له ذوق فالان
الجمهور حسب يعني خبرتي بالمجال والنجاح
والهذا الجمهور يحب السرعه سرعه اعطيهم
الموضوع
اعطيهم الموضوع على طول
عن عيون الناس ودي امنعك حتى صوتك بس انا
اللي اسمعك فالناس احبوا الجمله هذه ايضا
كانت في اغنيه ولا غلطه اللي لحنتها ولا
غلطه ترى زينك يحضر لي ملا عينك بس ولا
غلطه ترى زينه كانت هي الكلمه
فالناس الحين انا لما اسوي لما انزل اغنيه
جديده واسوي لها مثلا
في كل الاماكن في اليوتيوب في التيك توك
في الانستغرام احتاج اني انا اختار مقطع
مده عشر ثواني 15 ثانيه هو اللي يجذب
الناس للغنيه فهذا السبب الكلمه واللحن
والبساطه بالموضوع طيب يعني انت في كتير
رومانسيه وعشق وشوق مش بس في اغانيك في
ادائك باحساسك وبصوتك كمان انت اصلا انسان
رومانسي هيك بحياتك العاديه
اسمع منك اكيد اكيد
عدم الامتناع عن الاجابه وما يطلع شيء
يعني بهذا الشكل يكون في شيء انت تحسه
يعني طيب احنا أنا طماع بالطرب او بالغناء
شو راح تسمعنا
اغنيه جديده هذه ونزلتها تقريبا
[موسيقى]
نقول كلمات ساره خالد شارع سعوديه ايضا
شابه وكان اول عمل لها
والحان بتوزيع جسمي نقول
عليك وجود يخليك كل شي لا شيء يهون كل
لحظه عالي وجودك في وجودك ضي يسخر
انتباهيك وصوتك
صوتي بدل ماضي بالوان يحلي الحب واحزاني
على مودا وعلى شانه اسيب الدنيا واجيك وكل
الحب من بعدك ابد لا حب وكل احساسي من
قبلك كتب فيك
يا اول من اخذ عقلي ملك
تلقاه
انالك انالك انا لك انا لك انا لك انا لك
انا لك
الله الله طيب ما بين الغناء والتلحين
اللي هو الك يعني تجربتك متوازيه يمكن في
الاثنين وين بتلاقي حالك اكثر كيف انهن
اكثر كيف يعني أنا قصتك كتلحين وكاغاني
يعني انا نجتمع دائما احنا كادر العمل
ونقول شنو ممكن نوزع الفنانين نعطيهم
اغاني وشنو اللي ممكن نخليه فللاسف تسع
اغاني عشر اغاني لحنتهم وجاهزات ما اقدر
ابيعهم احس اني انا ممكن اؤدي فيها
ب 40 ثانيه عندنا 45 ثانيه راح تقول مقطع
نغير شويه موضوع يلا نقول وانا
بلياك
درميش الك تنزل
واذا
اتنافس بدونك احس
ويا النفس واجع وهذا انا حالي صار
حسيت ضيم الكون مخبوط وي دمي يا اغلى ما
عندي
مليت انا لوحدي كنت بحلم فزيت والحلم شي
رجعه مع سلامه الصوت احلام سعيده دائما
شكرا جزيلا لمتابعتي المزيد الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات